bro you want you want to talk about Elon
Musk body oh yeah no the Beluga
this is
crazy no but this is fire though this is
how you know he's working
like this is how I want my scientists to
look yeah oh that's fair yeah like if if
you're invested in Tesla and you see
that you're like oh we going to the Mars
yeah guarantee golden marks if you see
him looking like Jeff Bezos because Jeff
Bezos brolic as [ __ ] tan as [ __ ] yeah
pesos looks good but I know you're not
working I know that Amazon is in someone
else's hands and that's fine but with
Tessa we're invested in Elon yeah yeah
yeah and that [ __ ] is Were King
look at that thing right there looks
like the Ghostbusters logo
said he built like a deep breath
in the cartoon that's what he looked
like to me but I knew nobody would get
that no I don't know he looked like he
stung my wife in the Amalfi Coast that
[ __ ] is crazy right look how
pale he is oh my God but this is what
you want this is what you want from your
like lunatic CEOs yes you want them to
be that dedicated in the office not out
there not enjoying themselves I'm saying
though [ __ ] Mars bro go to Mercury get a
little tank get a little why is it
hotter over there yes right by the sun
he needs that yo get a little skin
cancer for [ __ ] sake you need to be so
smart to get that joke you just said
Elon Musk is dying laughing right now he
got that [ __ ] everybody knows it's the
first planet everybody knows didn't know
that all right did you learn the planets
in school yeah do you know them yep hit
it other than Mercury that's that's a
wash Mercury Jupiter Pluto Uranus yep
um completely out of order yeah this is
wild the Moon
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
think about Pluto is not a planet
son I don't know y'all making me feel
like I'm some [ __ ] dork this is very
basic
Ally I don't know the plan is you know
the planet stop it I don't know stop
playing dumb I don't know stop playing
dumb to impress everybody no that's how
you win people over yeah exactly all
right what are we talking about though
because Elon he's got his shirt off do
you guys care do you have a hot take for
this I mean he just looks like a joint
I I support it I mean he's honestly not
that bad built considering how hard this
guy working like you said how much he
worth yeah he don't look that bad like
Bezos on all the steroids this guy
clearly not doing nothing for his health
looks like that I think he got to be on
something he might even had a little uh
what's that called lipo oh you think he
thinks that like a cool scope maybe yeah
maybe a little he does have the calves
of a fat man he got some good ass cabs
on him he usually get those from
carrying around a lot of weight yeah
exactly so maybe he did get a little
lipo and that's why you know the Cavs
are stacked and the stomach's not that
big but son built like a deep breath is
perfect yeah right that's a funny asset
you know it's you got to be famous as a
dude for people to like comment on your
body all right like that's a different
level of Fame that's true almost feel
kind of bad for him too like you're out
at the [ __ ] on your yacht and [ __ ] oh
yeah I want to pour what a poor son of a
[ __ ] that is super yacht you go on
Twitter that's ripping your body apart
and you're like no no no I don't feel
bad because he was talking all that [ __ ]
about
right here is built just like Bill yeah
yeah he might be built worse low-key for
the age discrepancies he's built the
opposite of Bill somehow what do you
mean higher up top that's true yeah he
got a little like Mr Incredible if him
and bill the insurance salesman though
not the superhero when he had the job
even with the hair and everything but
like how much money does it cost to have
people not take pictures you on your
yacht oh he wants these out there right
he's trying to he's trying to get the
story away from his dad who [ __ ] his
sister yeah yeah like wouldn't you
rather people talking about I mean 100
his publicist is like all right Elon
what do we need to do he's like I have
just
[ __ ] Superman just rips his shirt
open I don't know dude yeah I think yeah
I think that they're just trying to
create another storyline kill a story
with another story kill a story with
another story it's a good point and this
is killing the story we're not talking
about it's shocking how
little his father having two kids with
his daughter has occupied the time like
the news timeline yeah whatever it is
like a week tops if that it got three
days I mean this is crazy yeah like he
should be in prison right
oh 100 that's some criminal [ __ ] you
adopted the girl once you adopt a girl
you can't [ __ ] it
that's a perfect yeah
it should be a law say again is it a law
though wait what does Nate saying
Nathan's he goes you can't adopt
something then [ __ ] it that's all he
says I mean he backs it up as the whole
premise is for Woody Allen you can't
adopt something and then [ __ ] well
here's the thing Woody never adopted her
his wife adopter would he didn't there's
always a loophole see yeah these guys
are good this guy [ __ ] adopted her
when she was four this is worse this is
worse this picture
yeah this is the worst it's it's bad
worse worse okay this is this is worst
worst is what his dad did you think
though maybe his dad being such a piece
of [ __ ] is what makes Elon so great talk
to me like a lot of times want to be
[ __ ] by his dad but it was it was
always his sister maybe you know but I
think if he got [ __ ] by his dad he
might be even greater if he got [ __ ]
by his dad he might be living on Mars
because having a shitty father often
pushes men to Greatness Jay-Z dad was a
drug addict wasn't really around Jeff
Bezos gave him up for adoption his
parents Elon Musk dad a piece of [ __ ]
you could go down LeBron James didn't
really know his dad so many great this
is another I'm touching another Nathan
McIntosh he's some similar to this but
greatness comes from not having a dad
very often or a shitty dad one of those
two you're like yo I have to be better
than this I have to push myself this is
like male ego okay hit it there's a
better way to look at that which is just
like
when it's left to just the mom
kids become amazing but we refuse to
give a mother any credit for like if a
good if a girl's a [ __ ] why not because
your mom sucks dad dad didn't come a
volleyball practice if a guy's great why
Dad wasn't around that makes you [ __ ]
great it's like if you're a deadbeat dad
no matter what happens with the kid it's
your fault yeah and no credit to the mom
whatsoever yeah she's killing herself
every day doing everything cookies
my mom's the real MVP and it was so
shocking it became like a meme we're
like what the [ __ ] women can do [ __ ] no
no I think moms get enough credit you
get the whole Mother's Day bro Mother's
Day I give my mom all the credit I'll
get my dad you're like I'm ruined
because she loves me too much my life is
so hard
I never said I was ruined my mom is
great you know what I mean
for nothing that's wrong with you
say something talk to my therapist
plenty of blame I don't talk about it in
a public setting it's too uncomfortable
see because it's okay to make fun of mom
bro damn I've never made fun of my mom
now on this podcast only compliment only
praise only praise a great woman